so let's take a look at the code that
adds the task to the default task queue
so it's in create conference in
conference API and then this is the code
that we already looked at to get the
profile get the conference key get an ID
for the conference key and here is the
code to get the default queue and you're
going to need of course when you did
this you would have needed to import Q
and Q factory so to get the default Q we
just call q factory dot get default q I
updated my code to use a transaction so
here's the code for starting the
transaction off your transact and then
we run it we run the transaction then we
get the profile entity from the data
store we create a new conference object
we save the conference in the profile
entities in the data store this is all
code from before this is a new code to
add the task you see here that the first
argument is off e get transaction this
is how you get the current transaction
when you're using objectify and then we
add we called Q dot add and then the
rest of the arguments to add our classic
option stop builder basically building
up the task options with URL task send
confirmation email good job I fix the
URL there and then the params we want to
send the email and we want to send the
information about the conference then we
return the conference from the
transaction and we finally return the
conference from the function